one of most important things I tell
people is you don't need to be an expert
in the technology need to be an expert
in the problem part of where we're going
is going from a world of scarcity to a
world of abundance right what do you
think prevents people from being in the
house one of the biggest boldest
entrepreneur thinkers that I have come
across and all the work and research
that I've done mister Peter Diamandis
how are you having good morning to you
I'm doing great
now Stephen you've been talking to my
mom and get him about me well I love it
and and honestly I think I think people
should know more about you I think
people should hear your message not even
for you and and I mean all the prizes
and awards and fortune called you one of
the world's 50 greatest leaders but the
the way that you think the ability to be
bold and and not take no for an answer
and push through and get momentum I
think the world needs thank you so
you've got a book coming out or it's out
now right that the futures faster than
you think it comes out end of January
January 28th it's coming out it's it's
an amazing read about how the whole
world is about the change you break down
basically every single industry and in
the radical changes that are coming what
do you think prevents people from being
bold I think a lot of people have big
ideas they can embrace the future but
they're there they struggle with
actually taking the action well first
Evan let me just take a second and send
some gratitude back your way for your
mission and purpose in life and the
things that you're doing because we
aligned very much in that way I think I
I personally believe entrepreneurs are
the means by which we make the world a
better place
you know I define entrepreneurs as
individuals who find a great problem and
solve that problem and in doing that
make the world better right I stand from
every rooftop and mountaintop I can to
say listen to the world's biggest
problems or the world's biggest business
opportunities want to become a
billionaire help a billion people and
most of us are stopped by fear most of
us are stopped by fear from
that we generate in our own minds fear
that comes from the television stations
or newspapers or fear of failure all of
these things stop us and slow us down
and there's Humanity in that but my
purpose and mission is to help people
see a very hopeful and abundant future
you know a future that pulls them in and
wants them to you know wants to compel
them to do bigger and better in the
world so you know another part of it
Evon is that people fear the future
because they don't understand and don't
know where it's going and as the as the
rate of change is accelerating and you
know we are moving faster than ever
before and in the book I write about how
the rate of Technology acceleration is
itself accelerating and so we aren't
going to see a lot of change we're gonna
see every industry not just a few every
industry change the next decade from
healthcare and education entertainment
advertising food retail all of these
areas are going to change I think
ultimately it's for the better
meaning it's to uplift people make
things that are cheaper faster healthier
better available to more and more people
at a lower cost but it's gonna change
the norm and most of us like to wake up
in the morning knowing that the world
was the same as it was the night before
and so we don't want to change so how do
we get used to it I think it is it's a
it's a challenge and I think part of it
is education part of it is getting a
sense of of where it's going you know
part of my purpose in this book is
giving people a look at where the next
decade is going so that it is less
fearful and more exciting anticipatory
so that you can anticipate where things
are going and learn how to incorporate
that in your lives as a mother a father
an entrepreneur whatever you're doing
so you're known for solving big problems
or also investing in and helping other
people solve big world-changing problems
what do you think is the biggest problem
in the world
you know it's interesting I think there
are first of all let me just let me let
me frame that for everybody which is we
are the lives we're living right now are
so incredible compared to way it used to
be and we forget how good life is now
and we have problems we've got political
issues we've got environmental issues
some people listening they have health
issues and those are very very real but
compared to how it was a hundred years
ago two hundred years ago five years ago
a thousand years ago we are living
extraordinary lives you know life used
to be about fundamental survival could I
survive the winter could I get food to
feed myself and my kids you know my
child is sick now what can I do
possibly and the problems we have now
are much higher quality problems like
man I can't get enough bandwidth to send
my 10 gigabyte file fast enough right
you know first world 21st century
problems I think a lot of the
difficulties we have in the world is
again coming down back to fear people's
fear of what they don't understand I
think it is people comparing themselves
to other people and feeling less than
versus comparing themselves to how far
they have come as individuals or
humanity has come as a species and
feeling extraordinary a lot of the
problems are self created we are in a
planet that is still has a large number
of political issues we're still way too
divided it's us against them in a lot of
ways versus us against the challenges of
the environment or the challenges of
pandemics or the challenges of perhaps
an asteroid impact
you know these external challenges these
um what I would call existential threats
for Humanity is where I'm really trying
to focus a lot of our us against them
let's you know bind together to solve
those problems which are seriously
serious problems for Humanity not not
the ideological problems that we
currently spend so much
she focusing on got it so my belief is
that the biggest problem in the world
and I tell this to my audience is please
that people don't believe in themselves
enough I think I think cancer should
have been solved by now I think I think
the woman who solves cancer is instead
working as manager at McDonald's because
she just either one never tried to go
into biology or two didn't believe in
herself enough to chase that dream down
so I think everybody has Michael Jordan
level talent at something we just have
to find it and believe in ourselves to
chase it down that's the the mission and
mantra of you know this channel and what
I do I love that okay Scelzi resonates
so so if you think that's the problem if
you--if we go down that we pull on that
for a little bit the biggest problem the
world's that people don't believe in
themselves enough and their abilities to
be the best at something in the context
of your new book - of how fast of all
it's gonna change what's the solution
how do we how do we then wake people up
to the fact that they can do great
things and believe themselves so it's a
great question and I have an answer for
that which is it's the single most
valuable resource for solving any of the
greatest problems is the passionate and
committed human mind isn't the
technology right so we're heading into a
world this decade not 50 years from now
not 20 years this decade where each of
us is gaining access to incredible tools
and these tools are AI machine learning
neural nets quantum computers that are
beginning to become available for free
online
you know biological tools all the
world's knowledge all the computational
power that you want and people go well I
don't understand how to use that stuff I
mean I can't go and program a quantum
computer I can't go and like you know
design a CRISPR molecule you don't need
to know how to you need to understand
what the problem is what is the
challenge what is the target you want to
solve a you to be sore you know Manto
maniacally focused on solving that
problem the tools the interfaces to
allow you to use these tools what I call
them is these interface moments
where you know we're heading towards a
world where all of us will have a
version of Jarvis from Iron Man this AI
software shell where you say you know I
would love to design a device that can
hold a hot fluid in it should have an
open part and a handle on the side and
you can you can visualize in VR and
speak to your AI and describe exactly
what you want and then see that coming
look you could you make it a little bit
larger and could you you know have it be
cost as much money and and say okay
that's it now print and not know how to
write the code for a 3d printer so ai is
going to become ultimately your
interface with the world in terms of
being able to utilize all the tools and
technologies it's the ultimate user
interface moment and this is going to
empower us they were the most important
things I tell people is you don't need
to be an expert in the technology you
need to be an expert in the problem
understand the problem I have a group of
entrepreneurs and CEOs I mentor in my
abundance 360 community it's about three
and sixty CEOs around the world and then
about three thousand entrepreneurs
digitally that I mentor then we spend
time focused on mindsets and moonshots
one of the mindsets you need in this
world how do I support you in in
designing your moon shots and making
your moon shots happen and one of the
individuals we have coming this year is
an incredible entrepreneur on her
seventh moonshot her name is Martine
Rothblatt on if you know Marteen Marteen
started life as a lawyer became the
founder of Sirius and XM radio and then
later in her career her daughter Genesis
came down with a fatal disease a version
of pulmonary fibrosis that would kill
her in some limited single-digit number
of years and Martine being the
incredible passionate entrepreneur that
she is quitter jobs and start with a
high school
textbook and with passion commitment
perseverance tracked down and ultimately
found and brought the scientist together
and developed a cure for her daughter's
disease and built a four billion dollar
from a company out of that and now has
moved on to next moonshot next moonshot
and so ultimately it really is what's
driving you what's your passion what is
it that and a lot of my work and I think
the work that you do as well is helping
people get in touch with that passion
understanding what drives them what is
it that you wake up with in the morning
and you go to sleep with at night and
that you refuse to give up on and so for
me it's around helping people create a
hopeful and abundant vision of the
future and then execute to create that
future right one where people are
excited about the world we're living in
that they're creating the vision that
they want to see that they understand
the tools and technologies to help them
fulfill that vision art are here and
coming and that we are more empowered
than kings and queens and more empowered
than the heads of Nations just fifty
years ago as individuals as
entrepreneurs
it's extraordinary we don't know that
power right so I look at the tools is
the tools versus the belief system the
tools have gotten a lot better a lot
easier but it's always been possible I
mean even looking at your story your dad
being in Greece raising goats picking
olives and then like being the first guy
off the island where everybody might
think this guy is crazy but he then goes
to New York becomes you know gets
involved in in medicine and that it was
still the tools he were available to him
now they're just more available to
everybody else on a bigger scale but
it's how do you how do you unlock the
mindset to jump back into your dad's
shoes to say no I don't have to stay on
this island forever in Greece I'm gonna
go off and do something bigger yeah so
that is that's that's the game as the
game that you and I are passionate about
sharing with the world and it is about
connecting with what I refer to as you
your massively transformative purpose
what is your MTP and I think a lot of
people are you know I go around the
and I in everything from fortune 500
boardrooms to graduate classes to you
know huge events and I'll ask how many
of you are clear about your massively
transformative purpose and I define that
as the thing you wake up with in the
morning and it's it's your beacon that
you're heading towards it's what's
driving you it's what keeps you up at
night what makes you excited which
allows you and ultimately you know it's
it's a fraction of the audience far less
than a half and I say there's nothing
single there's no other thing more
important right now to you and to your
family and to your company than finding
your MTP and by the way you can have MTP
for yourself for your family and for
your company ultimately for a nation
right America had a massively
transformative purpose when it became a
sovereign nation in 1776 and I say
listen there a couple places that you
can look you can look to what did you
want to be as a child before the world
or your mother your father a teacher
told you you couldn't be that thing
because an MTP a massively
transformative purpose needs to have
incredible emotion in it it needs to
have either aww and joy or pain and you
know and desire to solve because emotion
gives us the energy to keep going all
right a lot of my companies even as as
you know from what you've read I like to
joke our overnight successes after 11
years of hard work right right and so
another place you can look for your MTP
is if I were going to give you a billion
dollars and say kent's you can't spend
yourself you but you can spend it on
solving a problem you want to solve in
the world what would you do with it and
it's places like this that are again
flowing with incredible emotional energy
of solving a inequity in the world
solving a grand challenge or creating
one of your grandest dreams that is not
just for you but uplifts humanity that's
that's for me how about you where do you
how do you how do you
people to think that in that way well um
so I think the world's biggest promise
people don't believe in themselves
enough you've got Michael John level
talent it's something I think the best
way to do it is education through
YouTube okay if you gave me a billion I
wouldn't know what to do with the
billion dollars like I just put it right
I'll put it back into my YouTube channel
well like because I like I like I like
maybe that's a limiting belief I like
small starts and tests but you know from
here my home office in Toronto we have
two-minute subscribers three hundred
million views on the channel and that's
reaching people who otherwise may not
believe in themselves but I threw it to
you because maybe there's something
bigger I mean I want to solve this
problem that I I think is never gonna be
solved and I love it it's like you're
waking up and you're scooping out of the
ocean right you're never gonna do it but
every day it's when I wake up and it's
my purpose and mission in life every day
in every way you're making a difference
and in 10 years is gonna be VR and
hologram Peter and everything kind of
come into your living room you know
doing an interview um I'm always my
biggest my biggest hold back I guess is
I don't know what I don't know and so
you know here's the legend in front of
me who's solving big problems around the
world is there something else that I
could do or in a better way besides
YouTube because I think this is where
I'm investing all my time energy
passions having a huge impact but maybe
there's something more sure I mean one
of the things that was important to me
in writing this book the futures faster
than you think was helping people see
where the next decade is going so those
who are kind enough to pick up the book
I'm super stoked this is a work of
passion for me and something that I'm
very proud of this is my first book was
abundance the futures better than you
think and it showed us how the world is
better than most everybody thinks and
and the challenge is that we are you
know constantly bombarded by negative
news I call CNN the crisis news network
or the constantly negative news network
I don't have a good acronym for Fox yet
but at the end of the day the news media
their purposes deliver our eyeballs to
their advertisers and we pay ten times
more attention to negative news and
positive news and for that reason we are
glued to all this negative news I mean
like you know everybody watching try the
experiment count the number of positive
stories and negative stories in a
newspaper on a on a news channel it's
ten to one negative to positive because
that's what focuses your brain back a
hundred thousand years ago missed a
piece of good news too bad you missed a
piece of bad news you are dead your
genes are the gene pool so we just focus
on negative news and so that's their
business model but we don't actually
realize how extraordinary the world is
by almost every single measure so
abundance is a book that lays out across
every area food energy water healthcare
you know education shelter all of these
areas how we have moved the needle
massively and to show people in fact
where it's going so abundant at the New
York Times it was number two in the list
and then my next book was called bold
how to go big create wealth and impact
the world and really like you in service
of entrepreneurs saying you can play a
bigger game on this planet here's how
you do it and you know I've had the
pleasure of knowing some incredible
entrepreneurs from Larry Page a founder
of Google and Elon Musk and Richard
Branson and Jeff Bezos have worked with
all of them and my different companies
and so forth it's like how do they do
what they do they're friggin brilliant
yes but they also have mindsets and
clues of how they do what they do in the
book is really a shot in the arm for
entrepreneurs and then the futures
faster than you think is the third in
this exponential mindset series and it
really is a vision of where the world is
going over the next ten years so that
entrepreneurs can feel a certain more
certainty and a certain level of
excitement and a and a vision of where
they want to go because we're going to
transform every single industry we're
going to create more wealth in the next
ten years and in the last hundred years
and we're gonna make the world a better
place and yes we have challenges yes we
have problems but yet it's what the
tools we have to solve those problems
are greater than ever before and if
people
have a hopeful and abundant vision of
the future and a direction of how to get
there then they will be empowered to
create that future so that's what that
book is about I love it and Fox you can
call the fear overload Network I love
that I love that something as you
brought it up my main my brain went
instantly into problem-solving mode is
like we gotta get on I know we're
cutting it on time so two quick last
questions one what is your single most
important core value in one word Wow it
is its contribution I think my core
value right now I just came I just spent
the last five days with 20 Robbins and
date with destiny I don't know if any of
your viewers are 20 Robin's fans he's a
dear friend and we're writing a book
together started two or three companies
together and one of the things that you
do is you focus on your core values and
so grace contribution I have been sort
of for me core values but really how can
I contribute to the world it's it's not
about what you get it's about what you
give and I'm really refocusing my life
in that focus in that direction I love
it and then last one so chapter two when
your new book is called the jump to
light speed now we just recently crossed
20 years anniversary of gene roddenberry
passing it's crazy to think that that
was 28 years ago that he that he passed
away October 1991 talk about light speed
and visionary entrepreneur what do you
think he would think of where we are
right now and where we're going so I
know genes son rod Roddenberry very well
and many of the Star Trek crew and I
mean I'd credit Star Trek and the Apollo
program is giving me sort of Apollo was
like what we could do right now and that
scientific documentary called Star Trek
was showing us where we're going right I
love it I think I think gene would be
proud that many of his anticipated
predictions were were spot on right his
technology that is in the Star Trek
world much of it has come to pass or we
can see that we're going in that
direction
can I I just feel like you know the
challenges that that we face today we
are heading towards a if we don't screw
it up if we don't you know terminate
ourselves and I am hopeful that we will
not we are heading towards a Star Trek
universe in the Star Trek universe at
least in the original series and next
generation they live in a world of
abundance it's a it's a post economic
society right if you can manufacture
anything in a you know in a replicator
manufacture 100 carat diamond ring
all of a sudden physical things have
less and less value money has less and
less value and we're heading that
direction we're ultimately the ability
to create anything is the cost of the
energy the raw materials and the
information set there's a friend of mine
in the diamond in the Bay Area who runs
a company called the diamond foundry
that has a machine about the size of a
refrigerator in one end comes methane
water and electricity out the other in
comes perfect diamonds 618 carat
diamonds you know I mean they've built a
hundred carat diamond ring so we have to
you know part of where we're going is
going from a world of scarcity to a
world of abundance right it used to be
for example in the YouTube world that
Hollywood was the scarcity they had
ownership of the Stars you know the
talent they had Studios with the
equipment and then they had the capital
to do these feature films and it was all
about the studios were three studios and
they were the dominant forces in all of
entertainment and that scarcity mindset
right put your arms around something
indole it out a little bit at a time has
completely been dematerialized
demonetized and democratized weather now
there are craters like yourself or
creating content and garnering
incredible you know two million views
and such and so that same scarcity to
abundance in entertainment has also
happened in information and
communications and computation in all of
these areas and it's that which gives me
great hope that people are more
empowered with abundance never before I
love it so much the book is called the
feature is
faster than you think we'll link it up
down description below the man is Peter
Diamandis thank you so much for sharing
your contribution with us here today
thank you my friend take care if you
want to see the one on one I did with
Peters co-author on that bulk Steven
Kotler check of the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I think everybody's got something
inside of them that they are probably
better at than most of the other people